[MUSIC]
Virtual panel.
My name is Diana Nassar.
I'm a second year MBA student at the GSB.
And I'm joined by Hannah Ringel.
Also a second year MBA
student here at the GSB.
We will be talking about
our journey to the GSB,
the student experience here on campus.
And answer many of your questions, as many
as we can in the 30 minutes that we have.
We will choose questions that
most people are interested in
based on the poll results.
We won't be talking about the admission
process, the application, or
financial aid.
But you can contact the MBA admissions
office directly in case you
have questions on any of these.
To submit a question to us,
please feel free to just click on the Q&A
button at the bottom of your screen.
So let's begin with introductions.
Hannah, can you please start by telling
us a little bit about yourself?
Where are you from, what were you
doing before coming to the GSB,
and what are your goals after graduation?
>> Of course, thanks Diana.
I'm Hannah,
I'm originally from South Florida.
I went to the University of Miami for
undergrad.
And after Miami I decided to join
the Navy, and I did that for
six years as a supply and
logistics officer.
Mostly focused in Southeast Asia,
finished up in San Diego, and
then decided to come to Stanford GSB.
>> Wow, this looks cool, thanks Hannah.
As for myself I I'm from Jordan.
I was the product manager at
Amazon before joining the GSB.
And after graduation I would like
to still do product management but
probably in the tech media space.
Awesome, so
now let's get started with some of
the questions submitted by the audience.
So the first question we have is,
why an MBA?
What made you decide this was
the right time for business school?
Do you want to take this one, Hannah?
>> Of course, so
as I was deciding to get out of the Navy,
I looked at the jobs that
were available to me.
And they were mostly operations focused,
kind of leading teams of 10 to 20 people.
Pretty similar to what I
was doing in the service.
I felt like business school just opens
up an entirely different set of doors.
You can pursue finance, tech,
consulting, startups, etc.
And I really wanted to kind
of open up my options.
And I can tell you that after a year
at Stanford, that really is the case.
I don't feel like I'm
pigeonholed into operations and
that there's a lot of different
industries I can pursue.
>> Yeah, and this is actually very
similar to what I also wanted to do.
I felt that I just wanted to explore
what's out there in the universe and
what other opportunities are available for
me, and
this was the main reason why I came for
an MBA.
So yeah, it's either if you want to change
your industry, or change the function or
something like that.
I think that's personally
what drove me to my MBA.
Cool, so how would you describe
a typical class at Stanford GSB in terms
of diversity and background?
And I think that will be interesting,
given your background in the Navy.
So, yeah, can you tell us a little bit
about the typical class at the GSB?
>> Sure, so classes in terms
of a diversity perspective.
The GSB is really good at
kind of curating this.
40% international, 40 something
percent women, x percent minorities,
LBGT and so you got this really diverse
kind of demographic background.
And that really creates a much
more fruitful discussion.
But there's also ideological,
different backgrounds as well.
You see people from all different
ends of the political spectrum,
all different levels of
a socio-economic background.
And I think that just enables me to
really learn about my classmates and
what they're passionate about,
and just have a much kind of
better understanding of people and
what's out there.
>> Yeah, and I think also to that point,
I feel that in our classes we
have a lot of different and
diverse cases that we study from.
As an international student,
I sometimes see cases that are not
only from the United States but
from businesses around the world,
and I find this super fascinating.
And to your point around diversity and
inclusion, I really love that
recently you started publishing our
reports of diversity and inclusion.
I think that's a really good sign for
this school to also stress
the importance of the numbers that we
publish around diversity and inclusion.
So yeah, amazing.
How do you usually spend
your time after class?
>> Definitely, so,
>> That varies person to person.
[LAUGH]
>> You honestly feel like, especially
first year, you're deciding what not
to do because there's so many options.
You can do something
social in a small group,
social in a large group,
something professional.
Or you can spend more time reading
cases and working on homework.
So really is balancing that academic,
professional, and social kind of areas.
And now second year, it calms down
a little bit, which is great.
So I've mostly figured out
what I'm doing professionally,
I'm going to go into consulting
after business school.
So now, I spend most of my time on
classes that I'm really passionate about,
and want to kind of learn deeper.
And then attending a lot of the really
great speakers that we have here
at the GSB.
>> Yeah, totally, and I totally think
the same way, especially for first year.
We were super intentional
about community creation,
especially that we love others
then this year at the GSB.
It just feels like there is so
much going on after class around community
building going to talk which is one of
the most famous traditions that we have,
in which students share their own
personal stories with the class.
I've just enjoyed getting to know my
classmates, especially in the first year.
And now I feel like I have more
control to just do the stuff I like.
Cool, I can take this one first, and
I'll give you some time to think about it.
What have been some of your
favorite classes and why?
And I'm taking this one
because I know that I have.
My God, my favorite class ever at
GSB has been freedom, democracy, and
capitalism by Keith Hennessy.
As an international student,
I was trying to learn about the US,
and these three pillars
that define what the US is.
And I found this class fascinating.
And it's always really amazing to me how
the GSB offers classes that not only talk
about business.
But also as an international student it
gives me a chance to learn about America
and policy making and
all of these other issues.
So this has been definitely one of
my favorite classes, although I can
definitely talk about business classes,
but this is my honest answer.
Do you have a favorite class?
>> It's so hard to pick one.
So I'll just briefly talk about two.
I took a personal tax and investing class.
Which is arguably one of the most
practical classes I've taken.
>> You did, with Lisa.
>> Exactly.
>> My gosh, I want to take this.
>> And I mean some of the biggest
financial decisions you'll ever make
personally.
And I feel now much better prepared as I
do my taxes as I think about personally
investing.
That was great, but
I just finished up strategic communication
which is kind of a public speaking class.
Still got a lot to work on but it was
really great just to see how you are as
a speaker and
really develop that skill set.
>> Are you taking the four unit one or
the two unit one?
>> The four unit one.
>> Yeah, because I'm taking the two
unit one and I totally agree,
it's an amazing course.
And I heard, in the four unit one,
we also do writing as well, and
I just missed the chance to
do the writing, now I knew.
>> But you're going to do winning writing,
right?
>> Exactly, I want to do that,
too, and, it's, my God,
I hear it's going to be one
of my favorite classes.
Let's see, that's amazing.
Okay, next on, can you please describe
the opportunities available to
connect with students from around
the world and learn about the places and
cultures they come from?
>> So in terms of just Stanford or GSB
classmates, a lot of our classmates that
are international lead trips
to their home country.
I went to Lebanon with
Lebanese classmates.
I'll be going to Africa over winter break
with some of our African classmates.
I'm leading one of the global
study trips to Japan.
I'm not Japanese but
I live there for a couple years.
And I'm go and I'm leading it
with fellow Japanese classmates.
So one easy way is you travel to these
countries with your classmates and
then you just they're
they host food nights,
they each had the kind of
their own identity clubs and.
It's been really great just to learn
about people where they're from.
I got to go to Jordan but
not with Diana unfortunately.
But now-
>> We
can always work on that in the future.
>> We talked about Jordan pretty often and
you told me about your experience there.
And I talk about my trip there and
asking questions about life there.
So it's a pretty fruitful conversation.
>> Yeah, just by the chance to talk with
you and learn about your experience in
Florida, is also amazing for
me as an international student coming in.
I feel that your speech
creates this bi-directional
sort of channel of communication where we,
international students.
Maybe tell students from
the US about our culture but
we also get to know a lot
about your culture.
And, yeah, as you mentioned,
just one on one conversations, or trebs,
or even when people tell their stories
uptold, just like having coffee with
anyone is actually a great chance
to know about this, awesome.
So Hannah, as a navy veteran,
did you drove heavily on your
military experience in your
application as says and are there any
recommendations generally that you
want to give on applying the veteran?
>> Definitely, so I think reach out
to the veterans club we love talking
to applicants but
in terms of talking about.
>> How can they reach
out to veterans club?
>> We have a GSP veterans club page in
those like a little box you can fill
out there and we'll get your email and
someone from the club will respond.
But in terms of the application, I think
the best piece of advice that I got was
that it should be
uncomfortable writing it and
it should really kind of dig
to the core of who you are.
And for me that did include
a deployment story from the military.
I do not think it has to though.
I just think it has to be.
Something personal that really gets
to the core of who you are and for
a lot of veterans that is something
about their military experience.
because the rest of your application is
talking about all of your accomplishments.
Where the essay is the one part to really
hone in as to who you are as a person.
>> Amazing.
Thanks for sharing that.
So this next one, I'll take it first,
what surprised you most at the GSP?
I think as an international student,
there has been a lot of like
surprises to me, not only me.
But just like, you know,
moving from my country and
calling total different culture and
experiences and all of that.
But I think the thing that I
was pleasantly surprised at
the GSP is my classmates.
Just how diverse they are,
how slick amazing and
smart and ambitious and
driven people are around me.
I think that was one of the things
that surprised me most at the GSP is
that I thought that I managed
to create home away from home.
And just piece it out with people that you
can literally learn from every hour like,
basically.
What's surprised you most at the GSP,
Hannah?
>> I think it's specially second year.
A lot of times it kind of
feels like an all day podcast,
where you're just constantly listening and
learning.
And getting your perspective challenged,
kind of growing mentally.
And I think when you're working, you're
used to just showing up at certain time
kind of grinding and
then ending at a certain time.
Whereas an MBA student you just
really get to step back and really
have your perspective, challenge learn
about who's really interesting things.
And that's been surprising.
>> Yeah, amazing.
Well, I just want to remind everyone that
they can post their questions for us,
on the Q and A tab.
And, we will be happy to answer
them in the remaining time we have.
So Hannah, it's funny,
we were just talking about this.
We have one question about
the executive challenge.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] So, someone is asking,
could you tell us about the executive
challenge, first to your students,
parts eight and.
Well, I don't have much to say except
that everyone is so dressed out today.
[LAUGH]
>> One of the few days you'll see
everyone at the GSP wearing a suit.
>> Suits, yeah.
>> But it's a really great just
bonding experience with your squad.
So your squad is six other MBA ones and
an MBA two facilitator that you
do this whole first quarter
kind of experience with and then it kind
of culminates in this executive challenge.
Where you get a case and you go up, and
you kind of do a mock role play with
really successful executive alums.
And it's just a really good way to kind of
put all that you've learned first quarter
into this experience.
And I just, what I remember most is
just really bonding with my squad and
having a fun day to kind of
culminate then to fall quarter.
>> And like do some role plays.
It's like you give us kisses and
we do the road plays as
if we were executives now and
then towards the end once squad wins.
But there's no price.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's like a fun day.
That is amazing.
Could you comment on how the Bay Area
influences your MBA experience?
I think as someone interested in tech,
this has been very interesting for
me, A,
in picking which school I wanted to go to.
But B, I think just the fact that we
breathe the same air of the combinely
makes it sound like I mean, you just
cannot not know so much about that
combinely and what's happening here and
like the tech landscape and all of that.
And I think that's really,
really important
as someone who wanted to work in tech,
but I would say even if you're not.
And I would be curious
to hear your opinion,
since you are not interested in tech,
obviously.
I feel like there are.
There's access to all
the other industries as well.
And I don't know.
Can you speak more if you
are interested in finance or
consulting or
>> [COUGH]
>> Other jobs.
How does that influence your experience?
>> Definitely.
So
I can speak of someone that techs
great but I don't think it's for me.
And I'm entrepreneurship curious but I'm
not all in like a lot of our class mates.
But I still love being in the bay.
One, just to access to the people
that are around you are phenomenal.
We just get fantastic speakers,
if they're not already in the bay,
they cycle through and
visit, so that's been great.
You just got to visit very easily
all these awesome companies.
I've gone to Facebook several times,
Google, Uber, Waymo,
these are all like ten, 15 minute ride
away and that's been really cool.
And I just feel like there's
entrepreneurial energy at the bay.
And everyone is really trying to
create something or grow something or
change something.
And that definitely is the Stanford
ecosystem goes well with that.
>> Yeah and I remember we both actually
organized the woman and management trick.
>> Mm-hm.
>> To the point there's so
many companies and
I don't know ten or 15 minute drive.
>> Yeah, that's cool.
>> It was amazing to meet amazing
women from all these companies and
just hear about their experience.
So I think easy access is one of
the biggest things that we get at the GSP.
Awesome.
Hannah, what were your career goals before
you started GSP, and have they changed?
>> Definitely so my career.
I do have to get back to San Diego.
My partner's still down
there with the navy so
consulting made sense because
it allows me to do that.
But I wasn't dead set
when I came to the GSP I
explored a couple of different things.
I'm still like maybe I should do something
entrepreneurial next quarter on the side.
Sides, so I haven't closed that off.
But overall, I decided that just
consulting was the right fit, allows me to
kind of get that analytics skill set that
a lot of my classmates already have.
And really kind of get that first glimpse
at the private sector before kind of
thinking what I want to do elsewhere.
>> Awesome, yeah, and I think Not similar
to you, actually opposite to you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I did not have any curriculars before
going to the GSB.
I have been in tech for like all my life.
And so I was like,
I'm not going to do tech.
But once I came to the GSB,
I actually realized that I like tech.
I like it more than anything
else that was offered, and
I think that was when I realized that I
wanted to do it even after graduation.
I shifted more towards tech in media
because I figured that's the space that
I wanted.
But I really appreciated the chance to get
to know yourself more and realize more
what are the things that you like and
what are the things that you don't.
And I think sometimes reaffirming the
things that we thought we did not like is
also a good outcome of the MBA.
So yeah, I am just going back to tech, but
I am going back way more prepared, I hope.
And you interned at SAP this summer,
which is pretty cool.
>> My god, it's dope.
[LAUGH] Awesome, so we got another
question about leadership labs.
Can you describe your experience
with leadership labs and
what you learned most from them?
>> I think what I learned most from lead
labs was I was used to kind of interacting
with very specific types of people.
Like military style of leadership is
very different than the private sector.
So I think I learned a lot
more of those soft skills and
how to come off softer in less direct and
have more influence.
And you get pretty close with your squad
and they're very comfortable giving you
honest feedback in how you come off when
you are kind of leading a management.
So I think of anything it was just good,
honest feedback and
a very friendly warm environment.
And then just also kind of in a squad in
a smaller team you see what other people's
strengths are and
you kind of learn from them as well.
>> Yeah, yeah, totally.
To me as well, I think it's feedback.
As you mentioned, we keep saying at
the GSB, that feedback is a gift.
>> I love to say that.
And I think just getting continuous
feedback because with leadership labs,
you meet every Wednesday to do role plays,
and you get feedback on how those went.
So I think getting continuous
feedback allows you to see those
blind spots that you didn't
know about yourself before.
And I think that has been my
biggest learning from lead labs.
Awesome, I'll take this one,
I'll give you more time to think about it.
If you were to go back in time and
do something differently at GSB,
what would it be?
Well, it's hard, because I see now,
we already are,
we know what we've been through.
And so it's so easy to say,
I would be less hard on myself.
But I don't think that that would've
been the case if I started again.
I think, when you come in to a place
where people are super accomplished, and
smart, and everyone is just amazing,
you start doubting yourself.
And that could cause you to become
really really hard on yourself,
at least in my case.
But things ended up to be really
really fine and I'm good.
I'm in my second year.
I'm interviewing for jobs.
Everything's super fine.
So I wish that I had
this mindset coming in.
But I know that it's hard, but
this has been just my own experience.
Would you do anything differently, Hannah?
>> Yes,
this was a very easy one to answer.
I think I overcommitted on some
extracurriculars year one.
And the issue with that is then you
don't have the bandwidth or capacity for
extracurriculars later on.
So you get to the GSB and there are all
these kind of shiny objects and
you want to do it all.
And I think I said yes
to too many of them.
And now second year,
there are these great opportunities.
I'm like, I don't really have the time or
capacity for that.
So looking back year one,
I would have really thought about
each thing before I committed to it.
And really been kind of ruthlessly
prioritizing those things.
And then just really asking myself,
what will I get out of this
extracurricular involvement?
So overall, being president of
the Vets Club has been great.
Leading the Japan global study trip,
that's going to be great.
But there are a couple other ones,
I'm like,
is this really worth the time commitment?
>> Awesome, well,
this is great that you mentioned that.
because we have a question actually
about the extracurricular activities.
So can you tell us what are some of
the most popular extracurricular
activities here at the GSB?
Maybe to the lens of what you've done, but
also other things that are popular
that you haven't done.
>> Definitely, I think so
our vocal fellows, which we're both not.
>> We're both not.
>> [LAUGH] That's one of the most famous
kind of extracurricular things you can do.
You'll take touchy feely as a first year
and then second year, you'll be that MBA
to squad facilitator, which they're
all right now at executive challenge.
So that's a pretty kind of classic,
major time commitment, extracurricular.
Otherwise, there's a ton of different
clubs and clubs are like affinity groups,
and then clubs are professional kind of
interest and then there are just kind of
social, wine club, or eat club,
those kind of more fun interests.
So a lot of people join one of those and
take a leadership position in those clubs.
I mentioned, I'm president of
Veterans Club, that's been great.
People also TA,
I'm TA-ing next quarter for
two real estate lectures that are very
successful and really great guys.
>> Lucky for you.
>> [LAUGH] I know you're-
>> I already TAed this course, but yeah.
>> Right, and then people also work at
maybe like a venture capital firm that has
a relationship with the GSB.
Tons of people are starting their own
companies or working with a startup.
So there's so
much extracurricular stuff going on and
it's hard to kind of mention it all.
>> Totally, and to your point even though
our vocal is like the most pure or
something, I feel like I have done so
many other things.
And both of us have done so
many things that are not as popular.
But I feel that they spoke to us more
maybe, to your point it's clubs or
things that you just enjoy doing like
TA-ing that course or something like that.
I also love doing work with the MBA
office and just the admissions and
speaking to admins.
I think that's something
I really enjoy doing.
I also was on the Distinguished
Teaching Award Committee,
where we get to pick a Stanford professor
that we want to give an award to.
That's been extra fun for me.
So, yeah, I will just say that even if you
don't get into one of the most popular
extracurricular activities for whatever
reason, there's just so much to do.
And I love the sheet that we have you get
when you get in of all the extracurricular
activities and how much time
commitment each of them requires.
So that you can plan to avoid
over-committing as you mentioned.
>> But you won't avoid it.
>> You will overcome it,
it's just like, awesome.
What is the most valuable
thing you have learned so far?
This is deep.
[LAUGH]
>> My God, I guess.
>> This one-
>> I think maybe through talk.
And we mentioned talk,
that's where once a week to students
spend about 30 minutes kind of like
telling their life story and major events
or people that have impacted them.
I think from that I just learned,
you really can't judge people or
know what they're going through or
where they've come from.
And like you think you know someone and
then you hear their story and
you're like, I had no idea.
That's just been like, been kind of
like a fantastic weekly reminder of
the importance of you don't truly
know someone and showing empathy and
just wanting to hear
other people's stories.
I don't know that's the most but
that's just something I look
forward to on a on a weekly basis.
>> Yeah, yeah, that's interesting.
And I think the other thing
that was very valuable for
me is learning about myself more, as well.
I think that we do a lot of sort of
introspective exercises at the GSB.
And we spend a lot of time with ourselves
and journal and all of that in so many
courses that I think you just become deep
with you emotions and more introspective.
And I think just learning more about
yourself has been a very valuable
thing for me.
What are you looking forward
to the most next quarter?
My fiscal policy course,
[LAUGH] with Keith Hennessy.
because I just like it.
>> I took that one, it's really good.
>> You took?
>> Yeah.
>> You took all the courses that I like.
I think it's this and also low key
notes are coming next quarters.
So I am super looking forward to either
delivering one or even getting to know
the stories, like ideas to change
the world from our classmates.
>> Low key notes are like these kind of
ten minute TED talks that students give
and they are really cool.
But you're giving one the next quarter.
>> I hope so, the results
are still not out so we'll see.
[LAUGH]
>> That's awesome.
>> Are you looking forward to any?
>> Next quarter, so
that's when I'll be TA-ing and
planning our kind of big military
service community dinner.
I just learned that we got General Mattis,
former Secretary of Defense,
as our keynote speaker.
Which is pretty crazy to be
emailing with General Mattis.
And then also our Japan
trip's in the spring, so
kind of the last minute or
the last preps for that.
So that's kind of like when all my
extracurriculars will come to a head and
looking forward to like really
seeing the fruits of my labor.
Other than that, it's a good time just to
go snowboarding, easy to get to Tahoe.
And as an avid snowboarder,
I'm also looking forward to that.
>> Yeah, also-
>> And.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH] I only have around five minutes
left.
We've received so
many questions on the application and
again I would sort of ask people to
send the admission office about them.
But maybe we can generally
just take one question.
Could you describe your
application experience and
what would you do differently
now that you look back?
I think just like a general piece of
advice to all the prospective students.
All right that if I
were to think about it,
I would not have changed
anything that I did.
I would probably just be less
stressed out about the whole thing.
Honestly, what the GSB is interested in
is just, as we mentioned, knowing you.
So how can you present your story and
what can you tell and
show to people in the application
is all that matters.
I wouldn't worry about like getting
references from, I don't know,
people that are really famous in
the business world or something like that.
I didn't have any of these two
Jordanian people recommended me so
that's absolutely fine.
I would really focus on telling my story,
and yeah that's it.
That's what gets you off
the GSB I would say.
>> Yeah, I think what I did well of
the application was I gave myself
a ton of time.
I gave myself enough time
to take the GMAT twice.
That was huge.
Gave myself enough time
to really iterate for
a couple of months on my essay,
focus on my recommenders.
That was good.
I actually re-read my essay recently and
I don't think it was that good,
so I probably-
>> Same, same.
>> So I probably would have gone back and
done that differently.
I think it's kind of interesting.
I would probably say what matters
most to me now and why is like,
I'd probably changed in some ways or
at least I've had more clarity about that.
So I would say really just focusing
when it comes to your essay,
just honing in on who you are,
being authentic.
Showing how you created impact or how you
kind of resonate with the change lives,
change organizations,
change the world ethos of Stanford.
But it's pretty introspective and
it doesn't come naturally.
>> Yeah, and honestly, we didn't need
to make up anything or whatever.
It's like how do we show your
authentic and true self I would say.
So this is maybe our last question.
We have one minute, so,
I'll let you really quickly take it.
>> How did your experiential learning
opportunities effect your perspective?
The experiential learning that we do
at the GSB, like the role plays and
all of that, how helpful, or how did
that shape your perspective at GSB?
>> I think one of the biggest things that
you just learn is how to have influence.
And it's easy to just come at
people pretty directly and just how
to more subtly move a conversation to
[LAUGH] get what you want to happen.
And I'm still working on that.
But that has been a good thing
through the experiential learning.
I do not know if that is a great answer,
though.
>> Yeah.
>> You should answer it.
>> No, I think that is fine because
we are almost out of time today.
But Hannah, thank you very much.
And any final words or advice for people?
For like ten seconds,
if you have anything to say.
>> Yeah, business school is awesome.
It's two years to really
reflect on who you are and
kind of see that whole world
of professional opportunities.
Stanford is phenomenal but
all top business schools are phenomenal.
I hope that you end up here,
would love to see you here.
But you'll be successful no matter what.
>> Great, thank you everyone for
joining us today.
[LAUGH] Thank you, everyone in
the audience, for participating.
You can learn more about the MBA
program by visiting the GSB website at
gsb.stanford.edu.
Thanks again, and have a great day.
[MUSIC]